[Music]
welcome to this special edition of fox
nation i'm greg jarrett my guest today
sean hannity he of course is host of
hannity on the fox news channel
and the sean hannity show on radio
across the nation and he's just come out
with a new book
you can pick it up in bookstores or
online it's called
live free or die america and the world
on the brink sean great to be with you
first of all we're great friends i've
interviewed your
number one bestsellers um and i can
never duplicate it but
uh it's great to do this thank you for
coming it's a hot day so we start
sweating so people know why
um but anyway thank you thanks for
taking the time there's a latin phrase
at the bottom of the book explain it
live free or america dies uh
you know we were talking ahead of time
and we know the famous patrick henry
give me liberty or give me death we know
this the
motto the slogan of new hampshire's live
free or die
and i'll be honest i watched you
pound out every single word of your book
every night your two books
because your office was next to mine and
i
i haven't done a book in 10 years the
moment
is critical this is a turning point
tipping point
all those things we always talk about
choice selection it's the biggest in our
lifetime and the stakes couldn't be
higher
and i wanted to get it lay
out the case so anybody and everybody
could know exactly what is at stake here
and i've never ever been as
worried for this country that is so
great as i am for this country now
right and you know i mean it is every
issue it's not just some issues it's
everything
and i think the race has changed
dramatically in the last few weeks
and i think that now it's it is very
clear-cut
i can go through them very quickly we
can get into more detail if you like
but you know if you are happy with the
anarchy
the lawlessness the lack of law and
order
uh anarchist taking over city blocks
chopped chaz
spaghetti potluck dinner autonomous
summer of love zones where innocent
americans die
if you're happy with the oh on average
60 or 70 people in chicago
that are shot every weekend and they
don't do anything about it
biden and barack didn't do anything
about it the eight years they were in
office
if you're happy with the violence in new
york city or you agree with joe
on uh you know oh yeah we absolutely the
police have now become the enemy
okay there are some bad cops i always
talk during the whole
russia collusion issue and the deep
state about
the one percent but i always made a
distinction about the 99
the same same for police officers right
these are people that are putting their
lives on the line
every single day to protect and serve
their cities their towns their
communities
they deserve better joe biden doesn't
have one good word to say about him
the police have now become the enemy and
yes i support
reallocating funds they don't like the
word defund anymore because they don't
like the way it sounds so they've
focus grouped a new term but it's defund
that's what that word means
so that's law and order then we've got
higher taxes
i mean joe biden is running on
dramatically raising taxes on every
american
donald trump's tax cuts have created the
most
massive you know employment record
low employment numbers we've ever seen
and it benefited
all americans that have historically
been left behind
in spite of liberal democratic policies
that is at stake in this election
uh national security energy independence
what kind of people we want on the bench
or judiciary
originalists say versus those that would
legislate from the bench
these are profound deep issues here's
another one border security
or the united sanctuary states of
america
and amnesty and then free health care
for illegal immigrants
foreign policy you want if somebody is
fighting for better trade deals
successfully
all the predictions that donald trump
was a protectionist never came true
none of it came true but he did get
better trade deals with canada mexico
japan our western european allies
china uh and elsewhere around the world
and we're better off because of it and
american manufacturers saw tremendous
job creation jobs joe and brock said
were never coming back
this is just the tip of the iceberg this
is an overview
and as i got into the specificity in the
book we go through all of that
you do in fact i want to quote from the
book several parts of it page 60
if empowered democrats promised to take
or consider the following
actions and you list 30 of them i'm just
going to read a few
enact the new green deal ban fracking
packed the supreme
court got the second amendment abolisher
nullify the electoral college downsize
the military abolish private health
insurance impose a wealth tax a death
tax increased the top marginal rate
to 70 percent the list goes on and on
is joe biden on board with this
on board he's tripled down on it think
about that he joined this
insanity police of the enemy reallocate
funds from the police now look at
what he's now embraced just in recent
weeks and this is this is a phenomenon
i think it's a sign of weakness i'm
hoping that i'm right
you know we're less than a hundred days
away from the most important election in
our lifetimes
okay who he literally the plagiarist
that he is he's plagiarized let's see
robert kennedy neil kinnick
uh other people as well apparently
plagiarized
law school plagiarism right exactly
then he lifted and plagiarized bolshevik
bernie sanders socialist agenda
now what makes this unique is is whether
you're
a republican or a democrat usually in
primaries
you will go to your base you will try
and shore up your base because the base
is more motivated usually to vote
but in the general election you move to
the center joe biden
didn't have bernie's base he's adopted
and lifted word for word
his economic policies okay that is pure
unadulterated socialism
he looks to aoc alexandria ocasio-cortez
the congresswoman
he's adopted her new green deal agenda
and is pledging to spend trillions of
dollars
on the new green deal that would
eliminate oil gas coal
the lifeblood of the world's economy and
also offers everything to be free
it is mathematically unsustainable
impossible
these are dreams that could never be
fulfilled in any under any scenario
then he's got you mentioned guns then
he's he's working with uh
beto i call him bozo o'rourke uh the guy
said yeah we're gonna come knocking on
your door and take your guns partner
with him
then you got biden pelosi and schumer
they're elected you've got 125 years of
swamp experience
you've got 125 years of broken promises
you've got 125 years
what the hell have they done to make
this
country more safe more secure more
prosperous
and their track record is abysmal joe's
record as vice president is even more
abysmal
hopefully we'll get into that and so
you're asking me if they
joe biden will do that he's already he's
embraced it
he's owning it he's it is it is the
essence of his campaign
and what's strange and unique about this
greg is
democrats used to try and hide it they
used to believe it but they would never
say it
what makes this different is because i
never believed that the country
this country i always believed we were
right of center country
maybe not as conservative as i am or
maybe if you
are a conservative i'm assuming you are
i don't know for sure i never asked
you're more in the journalistic side
than i am although we give very strong
legal opinions
um i've always believed we're
center-right
but now and the left was sort of
marginalized
the bernie the bolshevik birdies were
marginalized the
uh congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez were marginalized
they are now embraced by their
democratic presidential candidate
this is the new extreme radical
democratic socialist party what does it
mean for america
if those policies are adopted i want
everybody that's watching fox nation
understand this
if these policies are adopted it will
fundamentally alter
and destroy irreparable harm will come
to the united states
the this is a pipe dream
this is a a prescription for unmitigated
disaster
and the america that was based on
capitalism liberty
freedom a democratic republic
constitution will exist no more
you want to know why i say live free and
or america dies
because what has made this country so
special and so unique
is that it's a country founded on
freedom
freedom okay barry farber i always call
quote him
he's one of the great pioneers of talk
radio and
just recently passed away and he always
would say there's never been a country
he says there's no perfect country but
there's never been a country in the
history of mankind
that has accumulated more power than the
united states of america and abused it
less i add
there's never been a country in the
history of mankind
that has accumulated more power abused
it less
and used that power liberty freedom
capitalism
risk reward exceptionalism can't say
that i guess today
american exceptionalism to advance the
human condition
because all of the advancements made
because we are free
and and brilliant americans create goods
and services that people want need and
desire
uh that makes them money and and some of
them even get
quote rich and they're horrible people
but you don't force people to buy your
services
or you don't force people to buy your
products
that has led to scientific innovation
medical breakthroughs it has led to
let's start with the simple stuff in
life
it used to not be that every home had a
washer and a dryer and a microwave and a
big screen tv and a refrigerator and a
freezer
all of these advancements that you look
that have now
i mean are throwaway cars in this
society
i own them when i was poor when i was
starting out my adult life
right and i used to fix them myself i
painted myself i did shoot tune-ups
breaks
uh altars starters you know anything i
can get done i do myself i open the hood
of a car now and i can't do a darn thing
i have to take it to the real mechanic
of the dealer
that's all because of freedom freedom is
on the ballot this year
one of the most important chapters i
think is
socialism a history of failure
uh young people today seem to think that
socialism
you know means free stuff uh they have
everything's free great they have
no idea that the history of socialism
you lay this out
meticulously is a history of failed
economies
destroyed lives impoverished communities
every time
yeah and every time is this what we
would be
looking at if democrats win the senate
if democrats win both the house and the
presidency
biden bolshevik bernie aoc
schumer pelosi this is their agenda
this this is radical extreme socialism
you're right about one thing it's
fascinating well we're gonna guarantee
um your your student loans forgiven
we're going to guarantee you
a job at the right wage we're going to
guarantee you a government vacation
government healthy food income
government government income
everybody all fair uh and we're going to
we're going to guarantee your retirement
and your health care and every
to me there's a there's a psychological
play in that and that
wow okay i'll never have to worry
the stress of life though this is this
is the beauty of freedom liberty
capitalism risk reward
is that there that stress is not a bad
thing
the idea that the government is going to
fulfill these promises social security
headed for bankruptcy
medicare headed for bankruptcy how did
that obamacare thing work out
greg keep your doctor keep your plan
save on average average family 2 500
per family per year no it's even worse
millions lost their doctors millions
lost their plans
on average across the country americans
are paying
200 percent more and there's almost 40
percent of the country now that has only
one obamacare exchange option
now that's just that one promise that
was the biggest lie
told biden wants to double down on it
and even triple down on it when he gets
to some deal with bernie and elizabeth
warren
if biden even is in full control because
he's now capitulated
to the most radical group of people ever
i was saying earlier you know democrats
used to try to hide this
they're now out in the open now the
question is is america
going to buy what they're selling back
to the psychological component
okay it's appealing that okay i'm going
to be safe
i'm going to be secure i'm going to have
my student loan debt forgiven
i'm going to have government healthy
food and retirement and
health care and okay sounds great when
you add it all
up it's 94 trillion dollars
in 10 years with the new green deal
because we're also eliminating oil
gas coal uh zero emissions
in 15 years according to joe planes cars
trains
well okay so that's the lifeblood of the
world's economy donald trump for the
first time in 75 years has made the
united states of america
energy independent and for the first
time and even a longer period of time
we are the world's number one producer
of energy energy is the lifeblood of the
entire world's economy now
if some great environmentalist liberal
wants to come up with alternative
energies
that are free lower price they're going
to be multi-trillionaires
great go for it but we don't have that
technology yet we're developing some
we have promise in some areas i'm an
all-of-the-above guy whatever's going to
work i'm for
i believe we should be good stewards
over the environment
the problem is and i don't care if you
take the former soviet union
scandinavian countries
uh european nations eastern europe for
east germany for example before the wall
came tumbling down
and every time
you give up your every time you take on
the security that they're offering which
always proves to be false
there's never been the socialist promise
that's ever fulfilled that is the
the failure of socialism
you give up your liberty and you give up
your freedom and what
usually then emerges is some type of
tyranny all right i mentioned in the
book cuba i talk about venezuela
if socialism was so great with all the
energy reserves
venezuela has they'd be the richest
country on earth
um jorge ramos went there and actually
chronicled people picking food out of
out of garbage trucks because of such
poverty
the when you have statism you it lends
itself to corruptness
it also eliminates freedom it then
becomes tyrannical
in most instances and all of the
liberties and freedoms that
did lead this country to the greatest
standard of living
in the industrialized world they all go
away
and and that is the failure of socialism
it gets worse in the former soviet union
you know
look at the wall for east germany west
germany
who wanted to leave what country the
east germans
were willing to risk their life to try
and get into west germany
right uh why are we building walls in
america to keep people
out in no because everyone wants to come
in
and it's amazing to watch immigrants to
this country and i've met so many
wonderful people in my life from all
over the world
they get the first shot of freedom and
the first chance to bring their
god-given talents to fruition
and you watch them soar i'll never
forget
because i've been financially
independent since i'm 10 years old
been a fiercely independent kid
people always like to famously write
hannity is a college dropout
guilty is charged because i was paying
my own way
through college i never took a penny
from my parents for money never i got a
student loan that i paid back in full
and i worked from the time i was 12
well eight with a paper out and then the
time i was 12
i was washing dishes by hand in a busy
restaurant every friday saturday sunday
uh then i became a short order cook that
i became a busboy that i became a waiter
then i became a bartender
and i always had a lot of money in my
pocket still do actually thanks to this
by the way it's 400 degrees just so you
know he picked the hottest day greg did
to be here
um i'll change shirts occasionally when
i need to the
but those jobs made me a better person
then when i was paying my way through
college
i'd make i ran out of money and i go to
work then i went into construction
i started painting houses then i learned
how to hang wallpaper
then i started doing reconstruction work
then i did roofing fell off three
stories of a roof
hit the ground became a conservative got
a little sense knocked into me
well this part of my arm from here down
was dangling separate
and um and i broke the radial head
my grandparents came here all four of
them from ireland they had
nothing they had ten dollars in their
pocket
my father grew up poor in bed-stuy in
brooklyn his mother died about five
weeks after his birth
from complications from childbirth
my dad it was a big deal he fought four
years in the pacific in world war ii
and and he was a big deal for him to
move from
bed-stuy to long island he was a family
court probation officer and a
and a waiter on the weekends and my mom
grew up poor in the south bronx
and she became a prison guard who worked
16-hour shifts pretty much my whole life
so but for them they stood on the
shoulders of
my grandparents their parents and i
stand on all their shoulders
and the idea is that you want to make
create an environment at every
generation you build upon
the previous one that's the hope the
dream that is america
how did we invent all these incredible
things that we have
you know you can go back to henry ford
you could talk about cars
you know planes trains and automobiles
uh construction
skyscrapers cities you name it that is
all american greatness and ingenuity
a lot of it is because of you know the
freedom that people have
to bring out of them what talents god
gave them the latin derivative for
education
is a duca to bring forth from within
well that that's predicated on what that
god put it there
what does our founding document say our
declaration we're endowed by a creator
though those are natural rights god
given rights
and you know we're doubted by our
creator with certain inalienable
rights life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness by the way you can't pursue
happiness
if you don't have safety and security
and law and order like in chicago new
york seattle and portland
you you can't pursue happiness if the
rungs of the latter are ripped
out from under you and and the
educational system is destroyed
you want to talk about the failure of
socialism in america how's america's
educational system
there you go you have a great city of
baltimore
you look at new york city you look at
chicago
you look at baltimore you look at
portland you look at seattle you look at
any
of the big cities in los angeles we as a
country spend more per capita on
education
than any other country in the
industrialized world government
run education okay baltimore
third highest per capita spending in
education in the world
the city of baltimore has 13 public high
schools
guess how many kids or what percentage
of kids in the high school are
proficient in math
yeah i would imagine a very low
percentage
zero zero not one child
really how's that socialism working how
will government government-run schools
working
i want to bring this to to a level where
people can understand
what's at stake here because the cities
that we've been talking so much about
and that this is not in the book but it
fits perfectly with my argument
that if you look at new york baltimore
chicago we could predict on any given
weekend what 60 shots
60 will be shot this coming weekend 70
12 14 dead uh how many children will be
shot we've had a one-year-old killed in
brooklyn new york an
eight-year-old killed in atlanta georgia
a seven-year-old killed
in chicago a 19 year old young man i
interviewed his father
horace uh lorenzo anderson senior his
namesake junior killed in the chop chaz
summer of love zone
these kids are never coming back we're
losing thousands of our kids
so how did these states that have
adopted their mini versions or
you know we say the states are or 50
experiments
you know they're supposed to be
autonomous in the sense that we believe
in in states rights and their ability
and freedom to do what's best for the
citizens in their state
but all these cities have one thing in
common they've been run by liberal
democrats for decades
they have failed spectacularly in their
number one duty which is security and
safety
all of them they've all failed our
national treasure
our children are dying our moms and dads
are getting shot
our american family our grandmothers and
grandfathers
they're getting shot and many of them
are dying you know the president's right
when he says
these are war zones he's correct
so and then you add the educational
factor
if you can't read write do math and
history
and that's what your government schools
are failing you on forget
america's dream it's your shutout it's
over
we have failed them there on that
spectacular level so
add the socialism all the promises that
you point out page 60 in my book
all of them and you tell me what has
government done so well
that would they would warrant us putting
more faith hope and trust in them
many of the arguments you're making
today are in your new book
live free or die available online
amazon.com probably barnes and
nobody.kennedy.com there's
there it is one of the chapters chapter
five to me is
is one of the most important it's called
i can't outdo you in this chapter and by
the way i thought of a lot about that as
i'm doing the chapter
it's called the hoax of the century
uh in which you explain in excruciating
detail but appropriately
that it was all hoax and the fbi knew it
was a hoax newly discovered documents
now show that
yet they lied to the american people
is this in your judgment the worst case
of government abuse
and corruption that you've ever seen
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in american history
you had two number one best-selling
books on this very topic both ends of it
um don't i hope you don't mind i stole
you know
because we called the same thing um i
watched you
go through the details there was a on i
called
the ensemble cast of us right you were a
big part of it uh john solomon was a big
part of it joe and victoria were a big
part of it
uh i'm gonna miss people um
sarah you but this was a three and a
half year
you know ordeal that this country was
put through
we were right and the mob in the media
was wrong
they lied now the problem is
is you start at the beginning you have
the same cast of characters the deep
state
comey strzok page mccabe
all these others they start with saving
hillary
clinton from a clear violation of the
espionage
espionage act you cite the law i have it
burned into my brain 18 usc 793.
the only difference between me and you
is you can give me the subsections and
bite in detail and then it was the
subpoenaed emails deleted bleach bit
hammers devices the all of it combined
and then it was russia russia russia
they were warned before the first fisa
application that
again the bulk of information in the
application says that the top of a fisa
aren't verified right
the bulk of information was hillary
clinton's ironically
bought and paid for dirty russian
dossier misinformation it became even
the new york times concluded that
and it was used to take away the rights
of one person named carter page
his constitutional rights and civil
liberties but it was done to spy
on donald trump the candidate to spy on
donald trump and his transition team
and in the words of attorney general
barr deep into the trump presidency
they were warned before the first fisa
warrant kathleen kavlik at the state
department said don't trust christopher
steele
it's unverified hillary paid for it
there's a political agenda
bruce ohr did it in august of 2016. they
did it anyway
then it gets even more insidious
and more evil because there's four
warrants in total three renewal
applications comey signed the first
three
um buentes signed one sally eight sign
one cave signed one the cape sign
rosenstein rod rosenstein signed the
last one
based in the last interview he gave
before the senate judiciary committee
said
knowing what i know now i would not have
signed it it was false information from
the beginning and the problem is
is that they dragged the country through
hell
they abused their power and they did it
to take down a president
they had an insurance policy first they
wanted to stop him from becoming
president that's why they saved hillary
and they didn't apply the laws equally
in that case equal application
equal justice under the law that was
gone constitutional order was disrupted
and now you have a few powerful figures
that think they know better than we
the american people who should have been
elected
now here's where it even gets worse now
we know
with the revelations recently and that's
lindsey graham's committee
peter strzok said we don't have anything
there's no evidence of any russia
collusion
but they kept it going anyway this was
early in 2017.
right they signed two more warrants
thereafter right
appointed a special counsel appointed a
special counsel
none of this who knew what where when
and then it gets even worse
because when people were put under oath
and this was the information that
corrupt compromised congenital liar adam
schiff
ironically the only guy on tape trying
to collude with somebody thinks is a
russian it turns out to be a hoaxer
he says uh so you have compromising
materials on donald trump
uh yeah i complimented materials
what's the nature of the compromise uh
and pics of the naked trump
naked trump has vladimir seen them a bit
of course vladimir
bussova naked pig you know compromising
materials
funny but not funny hillary's paid for
the russian dirty dossier
hillary did it they're claiming donald
trump now you have struck
and everybody on the seventh floor of
the fbi the
doj right most powerful people in the
world
take what they knew to be true and they
don't go back
which is they're required to by law you
pointed that out to me first
and update the application sure
okay unverifiable then debunked
right now we have so many examples when
they got to the sub source that they
interviewed in january january 21st
of 2017 three separate days of
interviews the sub source said this was
bar talk
literally said bar talk you were the
first to say after reading it and i read
it after you
that when you read the dossier it's like
ridiculously funny
right in a sick way because you can't
believe any of it you know
um then we find out they didn't think
they had improv they they had no
information
also confirmed in this very important
january
5th oval office meeting
biden is there he's the one that
mentions the logan act in that meeting
as as we now know from peter strzok's
personal notes
uh obama is there saying get our people
on this and maybe we shouldn't tell the
incoming administration things about
national security
uh what susan rice was there well that
was
january 5th 15 days later now we know
why she went back and memorialized he
said do everything by the book because
she know they did
she knew they didn't do everything cya
um and sally yates admits she was
shocked
that barack obama knew everything about
general flynn
and the call with the soon-to-be russian
counterpart kislyak
and the irony too is when you go back
then to the house intelligence committee
when we finally got those transcripts
all of these officials
said that they had also did the same
thing with their soon-to-be counterparts
when they're going into the obama
administration
but they all said the other same thing
and that is that they had no evidence of
any collusion
but they did it when we
when this finally it's going to be very
fascinating to see
what durham and barr ultimately do here
i believe the evidence is overwhelming
and incontrovertible
that this was the biggest abuse of power
i believe that people lied my sources
are now telling me that there are
lower ranking officials yes
some that we've never even heard of that
are
telling the truth and have evidence to
back it up
there was spying going on on another
side of this and that was across the
pond if you will
why did i always say gee i wonder what
the people in great britain were doing
or the people in
italy were doing or some of our
counterparts in
in australia because now we have an
intelligent side of all of this
and we now know
we we know that there are lies in the
mueller report
about joseph misfoot for example it was
western intelligence
we were outsourcing some of the spine on
our own
bingo to our to circumvent american law
that's right
um one wonders what would have happened
if the fbi had actually been honest that
we have no evidence
that it's all an invented lie but i want
to turn to what could i just say one
thing though
lisa page said it in the text no
it was struck that said no they're there
and lisa page said
this is pretty much the same thing but
they're only talking to themselves their
own little miniature evidence now we
know they were telling others
right page 124.
how does the fbi get away with turning
its powerful tools on the man the united
states citizenry
elected as president how do we end up
with a special counsel
who completely ignores fbi abuse and
instead
spends two years tyrannizing the trump
white house the answer is the swamp
so my question to you is how confident
are you that the swamp will actually be
held accountable criminally
well let me let me backtrack if i say
the title the book is live free or
america dies
if we don't get it right if there's not
a price to pay
justice is dead in america this is a
constitutional republic
i start out the book you know a republic
if you can keep it
right ben franklin and franklin and
if you don't that constitution and
you're the lawyer here
you're more versed in this than i am and
but i that is the foundation of our
entire
justice system in the rule of law um
the principle of equal justice under the
law and equal application under our laws
then
no longer exists i would already argue
that it's missing because the treatment
of papadopoulos
withholding exculpatory information in
his case
or for a processed crime of lying to
congress in roger stone's case
where 29 guys in tactical gear frogmen
pre-dawn raid guns drawn
and cnn cameras tipped off okay that's
an abuse of power
same with paul manafort paul manafort's
case was dead gone and buried
politico describes how it was a dnc
operative that got
that added mothballs because they wanted
to hurt trump
then you add to that all of general
flynn
i mean this is how we treat a 33-year
war hero
because they didn't think he was lying
but they said that they were going to go
after his son who was in business with
him
unless he signed that paper he was being
a good father he signed the paper to
save his son
yes that's what he did and they made him
do it
and he still you know it's been forever
for him to get the justice in his case
so the answer is forget it look i'm
going to be very blunt here
republics fail historically
america can fail america as we know it
can collapse
and the biggest part that i'm trying to
the point i'm trying to make as i go
through
what has made america i believe the
greatest country god has given man
the answer simply is freedom and liberty
capitalism against socialism now you
have the most radical group
of extreme socialists that are this is
what they're offering this radical
agenda
i give the history of the rise of
radicals i gave the 2020
utopian vision we talked at length about
the green new deal i talked at length
about bolshevik bernie's economic
policies i've talked at length about
beto bozo's assault on the second
amendment then
schumer pelosi and biden 125 years of
failure
greg i if they're if what they
are running on is ever implemented
buy buy american pie it's over
america as we know it will be
changed forever it will
irreparable damage will be done if those
policies
that they're stating publicly are
implemented
how serious am i serious as a heart
attack
serious that you know this all goes away
and i'll tell you what else is going to
happen
because i and i keep going back to the
the cities you know because they're the
the experiment right okay you've got
this form of socialism and high taxation
and endless bureaucracy
uh that exists in states like new york
in states like illinois
cities like new york city baltimore
chicago
states like california
oregon washington state seattle and
and portland the cities you know
anecdotally
why is it the biggest mass exodus in the
country is that out of those blue states
run by liberal democrats for decades
well reasons obvious people are running
away from burdensome bureaucracy
high taxes endless regulation uh
broken promises waste of fraud and abuse
and here's the thing how is it how is it
possible in california
you want to move out of california san
francisco
la go to texas u-haul costs we've gone
and checked
governor huckabee was the first to point
this out to me you know about 2500 bucks
2
2500 bucks to go from california to
drag your crap your stuff our stuff
whatever i move more often than i'd like
to have been in my life
i was a radio traveler for many years
and it but if you take that same u-haul
back to california
you don't pay 2 500 pay 400 and you
could probably negotiate a lower rate
you want to know why because you're
doing uhaul a favor
because they need the truck back there
because that's where the profits are
going to be made
after the disastrous coverage of the
pandemic
in new york new jersey connecticut
pennsylvania michigan california did a
little better i credit governor
gavin newsom for that he did pretty well
there uh
and then the lawlessness and the
anarchist taken over
then you add to that the lack of safety
security the lack of education
socialism government-run schools
government can't protect its citizens
and i'm just telling you this is a
microcosm this is a preview of coming
attractions to the united states do i
sound a little dire and
maybe not as optimistic as maybe some
people would like
well i'm not optimistic if this is
adopted
i want to talk about the media because
you do a great length
the mob the the media mob as you
describe them the liberal mainstream
media you argue they are so obsessed
with their pathological hatred for trump
they've dropped all semblance of
objectivity they spread lies
distortion and propaganda how
destructive
has the media mob been have they
squandered all trust
i can't even give enough adjectives to
describe it
the worst part is it's 99
of the media you know fake news cnn
is fake news to the president's credit
he has branded them for who they are
we've talked as conservatives i'm 33
years in radio in my 25th year at fox
this isn't exactly my first rodeo greg
and we've always talked about media bias
known about media research center for
all these years
it's never been this bad the example i
use is it's every second
every minute every hour of every 24-hour
day seven days a week every month
ever since that man and his wife came
down that escalator in trump tower
they have been on a mission to destroy
his presidency
with the help of some very powerful
people in the deep state that think
they're smarter than we smelly
walmart chopper trump voters uh
irredeemable deplorables as
hillary called us or that cling to our
god bibles guns and religion
or as biden says we get a chance to
rewrite the economy
and transform america what does that
mean
well we know who he surrounded himself
with
so the mob they don't tell the truth
they lied about russia they got it wrong
they
lied they hyped it was smear slander
lie besmirchments character
assassination you name it they did it
all
well and you were demonized for taking a
very strong position that wait a minute
where's the evidence
this is a hoax you got it right
because newly discovered documents
certainly
and the media got it wrong how does that
make you feel
you know i'd like to be able to take a
big victory lap
but you know number one we don't have
time there's too much other too many
other things to do
would have been nice if they would admit
that they've been wrong would have been
nice if they would
retract and apologize and correct you
know i make mistakes and when i do it go
on there sorry i messed up
now they're happy with their pulitzer
prizes oh yeah they get pulled surprises
for false
for false stories right um the
scariest part of it though to me
as i mentioned you and our ensemble cast
weren't many of us greg 20
in congress really all in to get to the
truth
15 more 12 15. 10 or 15.
okay we went up against the entire media
industrial complex
we told the american people the truth
you know and and hopefully justice is on
the other end of it
i i'll tell you as somebody that you
know his mom as i told you earlier was a
prison guard dad
you know family court probation i had
two family members that got to be
fbi special agents they were deity in my
family they were the highest of the high
that was the ultimate
so many relatives distant cousins etc
all became cops these are honorable
people
and i have to now go take on the fbi i
did
it went against every fiber of my being
but we were right
and they did abuse their power and they
did enormous damage to not just
president trump but the presidency
itself the institution and director ray
needs to get his
act together and fix the premier law
enforcement agency in the world
wow or get out of the way i know where
you stand i yeah
with christopher ray at the it won't
happen i want to
quote you about president trump no
president in the modern era has had to
take such
unprecedented sustained attacks by both
liberal democratic socialists and the
media mob
in an attempt to destroy him and tear
him down
do you worry that in the end
that powerful force may succeed in the
upcoming election
came closer than it ever should
i mean imagine how the breathtaking
hypocrisy you must take on
understand this liberals care about
obstruction of justice
right after the mueller report came out
they didn't care at all about the broken
the
the bleach bit subpoenaed emails deleted
the devices busted
the sim cards removed hillary clinton
hillary
clinton
correct they didn't care they care about
um russia russia they didn't care about
her
russian dirty dossier they care about
quid pro quo's
you got joe on tape bragging you're not
getting the billion dollars
and last you fire the prosecutor
investigating my zero experienced son
who's being paid millions and that's
only the tip of the iceberg i call the
biden crime family at this point
and so it's not truth that they're
seeking
they have the biggest donor in 2020 to
any presidential campaign is the mob and
the media
one of the reasons you know we've been
the highest rated show on cable for so
long
is that we do tell a story and give news
and information you are not going to get
anywhere else
and we actually dig for the truth and we
don't rush to judgment
and we believe in the constitution and
justice
these things principles like this matter
now
success you know how do you define
success even in the back of my brain
assuming that they're going to have to
choke on the words
we can now project that donald j trump
has been re-elected the 45th president
of the united states
by the way that will be worth the price
of admission
on steroids and human growth hormone
because they think they got this locked
up but
if they have to if to me i worry
if this is now where indoctrination in
our school system has gotten us that
they no longer hide their radicalism
and they've convinced younger
generations center left is where america
goes but it's really
hard left you donald trump will be
at best buying america time
now how do you fix that because there's
got to be a process of education
a process of understanding freedom what
does freedom mean freedom means that not
everything is secured
you have the god-given talents and
abilities the right to life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness not to
guarantee you're going to get it but
you have the chance listen i'm a firm
believer that
americans can't fail let's
let's create imagine in new york city
chicago seattle
l.a san francisco where there is safety
and security
of portland and let's imagine that the
school system is
rigorous education let's imagine
that the rungs of the latter that i
argue are missing from these
states of socialism experimental states
of socialism
are put back in place i actually have an
idea i think we should have
k through 12 curriculum online available
for free
for every parent grandparent loving
neighbor
that if the school system is failing
them they can go follow the curriculum
online and guarantee the education that
these liberal states have failed to
deliver on
they can't help with safety and security
unless of course the insurrection act is
put in place they don't want any help if
you do that we can save america
and by saving america you know what does
it mean
lower taxes limited government greater
freedom
um we have got to accept that
energy is the lifeblood of the world's
economy we got to produce it we got to
secure our borders
peace through strength not appeasement
you don't dump 150 billion in cash in
another currency on the
tarmac of mueller's that chant death to
america
if we put people that respect our
constitution
our foundation for the rule of law on
the courts
secure our borders if we give
you know health savings accounts
uh health care cooperatives that i can
prove over and over again
are working and saving people money and
it would give
every american even concierge health
care with access to a doctor 24 7
using new technology like telemedicine
just like tele-education
which could save a fortune you know
there's nothing america can't do we have
been the li the shining city on the hill
some people will argue in this day and
age well we have to
we're always been evil we're not a
perfect country because men
thomas paine once said we're not people
aren't perfect with the guides and
dictates of one's conscience
irresistibly obeyed he wrote in common
sense
there'd be no need for any law giver
that not being the case because human
beings are flawed
and sin and we have a propensity for
good or evil
but i believe we're all created by god
but that propensity which
which path do you choose or maybe chosen
for you because of circumstances
um you know he says in the best case
government is but a necessary evil
it's worst case an intolerable one the
the intolerable one
is on the ballot this year the wreckage
the carnage to the economy
incalculable irreparable harm
to our freedoms incalculable you know
this is a
this is a warning cry to every american
i don't want to write this book you
write great books it's too hard i'll be
very honest
it is hard work i did it because this is
the moment
of a lifetime live free or this great
country
as we know it if the policies of biden
bolshevik bernie aoc
schumer pelosi and beto bozo
are in effect i argue we'll never
recover
ever our future can be either
bright or gloomy pretty much
and november may decide that if if i
say in the book
going back to the very beginning is it
is it a monarchy or is it a republic
the republic is at stake here capitalism
socialism
energy independence or dependence open
borders closed borders
lawlessness or lawlessness anarchy
or law and order and safety and security
fixing america's broken educational
system
higher taxes lower taxes peace through
strength
appeasement tough trade deals with
partners
manufacturing goods at home saving our
manufacturing industry
so you know maybe i in a sense this is a
heavy interview
but i feel you know
with all the knowledge that i've
accumulated in 33 years
of radio now my 25th year at fox
i could tell you right now if people are
foolish enough to think that america's
freedoms are always guaranteed read the
words of ronald reagan that i put in the
book
right that freedom is always but one
generation away from extinction
and it's now our responsibility to
preserve protect defend
freedom and liberty for our children and
grandchildren and future generations
that's how serious i see it as i'd
rather joke around and talk about
baseball
i talk about football i'd rather talk
about other things we could talk about
them on november 4th
and let's hope the media chokes on those
words to choke on it
be worth the price of admission cnn we
can now
project donald j trump been reelected
you imagine them having to say that i
lived through eight years of
obama i don't think we can live through
eight years of
bolshevik bernie aoc joe pelosi schumer
and beto
sean hannity thank you very much the
name of your new book coming out
is live free or die i read a cover to
cover it's beautiful
i saw you mark it up it's beautifully
written
the arguments are compelling well
researched thank you thoroughly sourced
and you told me you were never going to
write another book again a couple of
years ago and here it is
you you did it and you know i think uh
the readers in america
owe you a debt of gratitude uh all i
want is if anybody
if you say to yourself what can i do if
all you can do is vote
thank you if you can educate people
that's what this book is about
don't buy two copies share it pass it
around my last book i gave every penny
away to charity
it's not about this for me is about the
moment
this is this is america on the verge
tipping point it's all on the line to
win
an election for a republican is not easy
greg you got to take
you got to win florida georgia north
carolina
you got to take iowa you got to get ohio
you got to
pick off pennsylvania wisconsin
hopefully michigan maybe minnesota will
be in play
you gotta hold arizona fight for nevada
fight for new mexico fight for new
hampshire
fight for the second congressional
district in maine they all matter
every vote matters you've been a good
sport uh due to covet and social
distancing we chose it's
100 degrees and i just worked get it
outdoors
and you're sweating like a pig you're a
great sport about it no no
thank you for coming it's an honor to a
great colleague and a good friend thank
you same here
for being with us thank you so much greg
and that's it for this special edition
on fox nation i'm greg jarrett thanks
for being with us
you